everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're continuing our
coverage of the 2018 World Chess
Championship between Magnus Carlsen The
Champion and Fabiano Caruana the
Challenger the first five games have all
been draw some more exciting than others
Magnus Carlsen not new to this
the last championship he had against
there to get a caddie yakun they drew
the first 7 game so this is not uncommon
at all but what that brings us to game
number 6 Magnus Carlsen
playing the white pieces he's changed
things up everytime last time how he
played the English opening his also
played pawn to d4 today he starts out
with pawn to e5 now in the past he's
really tried to avoid this line because
he knows how much Fabiano enjoys the
petrov so as soon as we saw this we was
curious to see if Magnus Carlsen was
going to go down that path or if he was
gonna try something else
after Ponce 'if I've as expected we did
see Knight to f3 and immediately we saw
Fabiano played Knight to f6 now there's
an entire video on the Petrov defense if
you haven't watched that video feel free
to go watch that if you want to be
familiar with how this plays out but
definitely something that Fabiano it's
one of his favorite openings he's very
familiar with it so interesting to see
Magnus Carlsen getting in his
preparation to say yes I I know this is
one of my opponents favorite moves I'm
still going to play it as white madness
decides to go with the classical line
Knight takes here on e5 and then pawn to
d6 for those who haven't seen the video
are just not too familiar with the petra
of defense this is typically gonna be
the play here pawn to d6 forcing the
knight to come back and retreats more
than likely you see that because Knight
taking here on e4 just is not as good
Queen here to e2 attacking the knight
and then you know where does black go
from here Knight to f6 is the worst move
because Knight to c6 this is a
discovered attack and the queen is going
to fall so you know definitely not going
to do that but from here if you tried
something like pawned
2d6 okay well the Queen's going to come
up here
maybe pawn takes but then the Queen just
takes if you just continue to mirror the
moves Queen to e7
well Queen takes here Queen can't take
back so maybe pawn to d6 here but then
pawn d4 if the pawn takes Y it's gonna
recapture y it's gonna be up in material
so that's why pretty much always it
makes sense to play pawn to d6 forcing
the knight to come back and then the
pawn is gonna be free for black to take
but 99% of time White's gonna just come
back to f3 Magnus Carlsen has other
plans and he plays the pretty unique
move of Knight to d3 not gonna keep it
there as you can see it is blocking off
the development of the pawn here on d2
also blocking off the light square
bishop would get involved but just
getting set up to go to a place where he
wants to so after Knight takes on e4
then we see Queen 2 e 2 pinning down
that night and then Queen to e7 don't
want to try to hold on to this by
playing something like pawns f5 say yeah
you can't take my knight right here all
the thin it with my pawn because pawn to
f3 completely blows that out of the
water so from here as you can imagine
these players playing the correct moves
Queen to e7 Knight over here to f4
Knight to c6 just symbol develop move
from black and then Knight to d5 so an
interesting way Magnus Carlsen is
approaching this to attack this Queen
here on e7 black can move the Queen or
he can move his own Knight to attack the
Queen and that's exactly what we see
Knight down here to a d4 and then both
the Queen's come off the board very
interesting to see in this position they
just hey let's bring both of our Queens
here to e2 any 7 and then exchange those
and then the Knights immediately retreat
here die back here to d5 and then Knight
to d4 that's definitely gonna be better
yes this Bishop may look tempting to go
ahead and take but if this Knight takes
on c1 first you have to keep in mind
that the knight can come up here to c7
so that's the first thing check that is
gonna fork the rook over here on a8
but things get even worse so King to d8
the knight takes here maybe the bishop
moves to get the King over here to take
that night but pawn to f3 forcing this
Knights move Knight comes back let's say
f6 and then I'd up here to c3 and now
the rook is attacking this nights here
on c1 so things not going to go well at
all
so in the game we see Fabiano bring his
Knights back here to a d4 now Knight to
a3 this knight on d4 is attacking the
pawn on c2 so both sides are attacking a
fork with their opponents King to
capture a rook so let's kind of look at
the positions because this is what both
Fabiano Magnus Carlsen are looking at
Magnus Carlsen has the option right away
to go ahead and take with his own night
this is check he can freely take this
rook here if he does take things don't
look as great these sounds a very active
night here on e4 and that's what magnus
carlsen is looking at this is going to
be the same
check fork King comes to e to do not
want to bring it over here to d1 because
you're just gonna lose to night to f2 so
instead have to bring your king to e2
blocking off your light square bishop
that's not good night to a-1 maybe now
pawn to d3 this is forcing the Knights
back Knight to c5 punt up here b4 that
over here to a4 but you can see here
from White's perspective just doesn't
have a great foundation as far as moving
forward it is Kings not really worried
wants to be it is blocking the bishop
right here his pawns don't have a very
good structure and he has the night over
here on a8 now compare that to what
happens in the real game he says okay I
know I have this attack but I'm also
cognizant of the fact that my opponent
can take here on a c2 so I'm gonna go
ahead and play Knight to a3 I still have
my strong attack but I do want to stop
this attack here on c2 Knight comes back
to e6 upon f3 forcing the Knights come
back now pawn up here to D for
controlling the center of the board and
the night comes back to
d7 and then pawn to d3 so you can see in
this position how how much better it is
from whites perspective to go along this
path and if you are looking at this
curious after pawn to d4 why the knight
didn't come down here just keep in mind
that black has to be aware of the night
coming up here to c7 and forking that
King so he does need to keep his nights
here on e6 which is why madness can
freely bring his pawn up here to d4 so
after Knight d7 pawn c3 solidifying the
pawn chain much better position for
Magnus Carlsen pawn to c6 a forcing and
the Knights move Knight comes back here
to f4 night here b6 Bishop to a d3 just
opening up the board if white wants to
castle on the King side not as important
to castle once the Queen comes off the
board but you never know you may want to
get your rook involved very very quickly
pawn to d5 just counter-attacking in the
center of the board Knight to c3 once
the knight came over here to a3 to
support the c2 file right now it's not
doing much of anything can't come here
to b5 or c4 so it needs to get involved
it's not doing anything on the a file so
it comes back here to C 2 so we can
start to be more active Bishop to d6
same thing once to get it centralised
also opens up the door to castle on the
Kings side if Fabiana wants to white
decided to go ahead and take here Bishop
recaptures and then King to f2 so not
gonna Castle wants to get as centralized
as possible punished 5 so yeah I don't
want you to push any further on the King
side pawn here to h4 and then I'd appear
to a c8 so Fabiana looks at it he wants
to get his knight involved it's kind of
blocked off on the Queen side of the
board as far as how he can continue I
mean he does have the option of c4 does
it look like an outpost but from here
we're just gonna see pawn to b3
where does black really go from here he
can't come down to any of these squares
it's going to fall if he just comes back
here to b6 well that was really a wasted
move you just have a better position
from white and now it's White's move if
he comes back to a5 well now it's just
really hanging out it's not doing too
much at all it's not
now I can't come here to c6 or b7 so in
the game definitely could have played
Knight to d7 I think this makes sense as
well but the way you wanted to position
it he decided to go in and play c8 so he
could bring it to East 7 and then bring
it to some other critical squares in his
game plan Knight to e3 magnets looking
to get his knight too involved as well
Knight to e7 pawn up here to g3 just
starting to push a little bit on the
kingside pawn c5 Bishop back here to see
tube and then castle on the King side
for black if you look at this board
state it's tough to figure out exactly
how Magnus continues really both sides
for that matter but you know we could
see Magnus Carlsen play pawn to b3 you
know he didn't play this earlier because
Fabiana didn't bring his night down here
be good just play it's a great square he
could play Bishop to b3 if he wants to
cut it control this light diagonally
both has his knights and its bishop
eyeing this down could also play pawn to
a3 if he wants to worry about the dark
squares a little bit more could also
just play Bishop here to d2 if he wants
to he opted for rook to d1 I think a lot
of these are just personal preference
and then as you look down you know the
path and figure out where you think your
opponent's gonna go
Magnus thought that it's more important
to control the center with his rook rook
over here to d8 also controlling the
center Knights to g2 pawn takes pawn
recaptures there is now an isolated pawn
in the middle for both sides this does
open up the door for some of the rooks
to control open files that's exactly
what Fabiana does immediately he plays
rook here to c8 Bishop to b3 attacking
this isolated pawn in the center Knight
to c6 attacking the exact same thing
from whites point of view Bishop to f4
and then a knight over here to a5
attacking and the bishop rook to see one
says yeah if you want to exchange I'll
go ahead and do that Bishop over here to
be for Bishop down to d1 and then Knight
to c4 you can start to feel like Fabiano
has a good strong attack
in him his board say definitely looks
more aggressive than magnus carlsen
Magnus doesn't feel super company's
retreating all of his pieces making sure
he doesn't make mistakes but definitely
doesn't feel like he is the aggressor in
the game now ponzu be three and then
Knight to a3 this is setting up for the
bishop to come to c3 really this rook
would not have a good option there he's
going to fall if it's on a 1 or b1 so
from here really the only good option
for whites come up here take on c8 after
the rook takes then the rook swings over
here to see one still is protected by
the bishop fortunately for Magnus here
on f4 but this is the one way to go
ahead and save his rook so since that
attack doesn't work out and I comes back
here to b5 attacking this pawn here on
d4 not a defender currently on this pawn
so Magnus decides to go ahead and take
right here and after the bishop takes
now I can come to e3 now the knight on
e3 is attacking the pawn on d5 it's no
longer being defended by the bishop on
e6 I think it makes the most sense from
here just to come back to e6 you're
defending this square you still have
United attacking the pawn here on d4 I
don't think it's very easy for white to
defend that correctly but in the game we
did see Fabiano come down here play
Knight to D or excuse me c3 bishop to a
c2 bishop down here to a3 bishop over
here to b8 attack in the pond pretty
easy from Fabiano just to play pawn to
a6 pawn f4 on the King side
Bishop to d7 pawn starts to push a
little bit more since it is defended by
the night here on e3 Bishop c6 Bishop
down here to d1 attacking the pawn on h5
this is another spot where I really
thought we would just see the knight
take here on d1 this does leave black
with the bishop pair and going into the
end game with pawns on both sides of the
board I feel like this would be good for
Fabi on him but from here Fabiana it
might play King to f8 a Bishop to a7
King e 7
93 I guess he just looked at this
position didn't feel like his bishops
were gonna do all that much so he
actually let it go did not I'll worry
about the bishop coming up and taking
here on h5 and said he decided to play
Bishop to b2 and after the bishop takes
then Knight to e4 this is a great
outpost also checking the Keane after
the the King moves then he's free to
take this Bishop here on d4 so he does
have a passed pawn first pass pawn he
does want to push this gonna be somewhat
difficult with three minor pieces eyeing
down on that pawn but that is plan
numero uno for Fabiano Caruana Bishop
comes down to F for Bishop up here c5
Bishop f3 it's hacking the night tonight
comes down here to d2 then we start to
see a lot of exchanges from Magnus
Carlsen you can look at the material it
is equal on both sides but the Magnus
Carlsen decides to do a pretty
interesting exchange here takes the pawn
here on d5 Bishop comes down here takes
the Knights bishops gonna capture
material here on c6 Bishop takes on f4
starts to gobble up these pawns over
here and then you can see right away
that Magnus Carlsen he gave up his
knights in exchange for three pawns now
getting into the endgame this does favor
Fabiano yes he only has two pawns but
his minor pieces and his King should be
able to overpower his opponent and
gobble up some of those pawns to get a
both material advantage as well has you
know nice positional advantage as well
Knight here to e4 pawn up here to g4
Bishop down to a3 Bishop to a c4 King to
FA just getting involved into the game
pawn pushing to g5 Knight over here to
c3 and you can see there's no way to
stop once the bishop came down here
stopping this pawn on the a file from
pushing now Knight to c3 is going to
gobble up the material pawn to b4 says
yeah I'm I'm opening up the door for my
life to her Bishop to defend this I'm
also just giving up this pawn so it came
down to which pawn he wanted to lose he
chose to lose his pawn on the B file so
it takes that pawn Fabiano goes up upon
him
two year old king here to f3 Knight to
a4 then the night maneuvers around pawn
to a4 this is an outpost not the best
outpost not going to be doing too much
for Magnus Carlsen and then pawn up here
to f6 want to make sure he gets his
pawns on dark squares especially if your
opponent only has one Bishop you want to
see what Square that's on it's on the
light square so this lighter bishops not
gonna be doing any damage to these ponds
that Fabiano has so very smart from him
you know very good in in game making
sure that he does have those on dark
squares King to g4 Knight over here to
e4 and we started to see some
maneuvering from black bishop down here
to e1 Bishop e3 or d3 attacking the
knight Knight to d6 getting a safer
Square also attacking the pawn here on
f5 so the bishop is now tied down to
this pawn can get his King back here if
he wants to but now this bishop starting
to have to do double duty then he plays
pawn to e5 I thought this was a a
mistake for Magnus Carlsen he did not
have to play this just giving up a free
pawn - Fabiano and you can start to see
the lead increase from Fabiano here he
does have you know a minor piece in
exchange for now just one pawn in the
game pawn takes on f6 pawn recaptures
and this pawn is extremely important for
Fabiano yes you can technically win a
game with a bishop and a knight but it's
not going to be easy to just get to an
endgame with those minor pieces verse
your opponent's king so this pawn if he
can keep it around that is his winning
strategy King here to g6 Bishop up here
to the 8 wants to protect that pawn king
to h7 and that up here to f7 Magnus
Carlsen knows he's in just defend mode
he can't really win from here although I
mean he could essentially promote his
pawns he does have a passed pawn here on
the H file but knowing that his
opponent's up a lot in material he's
really just trying to draw Bishop down
to c4 Knight to e5 outpost attacking the
bishop bishop to d5 both sides just
maneuvering pieces back and forth trying
to see if there's something that they
can
find in the game what's interesting is
that after move 64 Bishop here to c4
there's always computers going on
analyzing all these moves if you're
watching it live on a lot of the
different sites they show you lots of
different options from the computers
that's both to help the people watching
it that they're not familiar who is
actually winning they can tell you lots
of different lines as far as how both
sides can play you can even play your
own moves and see what that would do to
a computer rating but there's also super
computers on different sites that are
analyzing this as well one of this is
the super cuter supercomputers looked at
this and said that there's a forced mate
in 30 moves for Fabiano now most of the
other computers were looking at this
saying that there's you know a lot of
different options that black would have
here he could play Knight to f3
he could play Knight to c6 if he wanted
to he could even play Bishop here to h4
those are all fine options none of those
in animates but the supercomputer of
well beyond human intelligence found a
mate in 30 no way to stop at a lot of
different ways they actually ended up in
a quicker mates but that was if magnus
carlsen defended correctly Fabiano did
not find the line in this position he
the optimal move they said was Bishop
here to h4 he played Knight to f3 which
looks completely fine but King to h7
Knight here to e5 Bishop down to b3
and you can see Fabiano just moving
around trying to find something thinking
about the long game if there's something
he can do to come up with a victory
moves around a lot not able to find
anything and then in this position right
here on move 79 he played Knight to e3
and this really just gives up his
advantage that he had the night here on
g4 was so important because the pawn
can't come to h6 he can come up here
take it
it's being defended by the bishop here
as soon as he comes down to e
then pawn to age six black has to take
it right here he can't let the pawn come
up here to age seven because then black
would actually lose the game so he plays
pawn to age six Bishop takes on age six
this is going to fall and at the end of
this he realizes that his advantage has
gone he was not able to find a mate and
so they draw just one move after he
played that night to e3 he's still gonna
be extremely difficult even if he didn't
play this to find the mates because he
did miss the mate in 30 which who's
actually gonna find matin thirty so
after six games we still have a draw
throughout I'd say this was one of the
more interesting ones I think this end
game will be analyzed for many years to
come I did like the fact that both
players continued to play this was not a
let's play for 33 moves just get past
that minimum threshold of 30 moves and
then we'll just do a quick draw like
we've seen the past few games so they
actually did try it out
I like the Magnus Carlsen tried playing
Fabiano's strengths in the early game
Fabiano showing what he does in that
specific defense he knows just so many
good variations and how to actually
maneuver his pieces he ended up in a
better middle game going into the in
game just was not able to capitalize so
we will have a break tomorrow and then
we will come back for a game number 7
and remember Magnus Carlsen will have
the white pieces so having white two
times in a row and then I'll switch
Magnus Carlsen I will end up with the
black pieces in the final game game 12
if it goes to that but thank you guys so
much for watching hopefully you are in
doing the analysis and the World
Championship no we haven't had it in a
couple year or so although I myself as a
commentator as well as a fan would like
to see a lot of wins I still enjoying
this high level of chess hopefully you
are as well I'll see you in game 7 a
couple days thanks again for watching
bye